[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas comme ça la vie Rachel
tous les jours c'est dur c'est un combat
et pourtant il faut faire avec c'est
comme ça
nous avons tous que nous sommes vivants
et pourtant on continue encore à
survivre
parfois même le paradoxe est constitué à
petit feu consciemment
mais c'est quoi cette vie
alors voilà
pour moi cette plante
illustre parfaitement ce qu'est la vie
elle expose juste là
tout ce qu'on accepte de voir et surtout
de ne pas voir
risque de décevoir certains je n'ai pas
d'histoire extraordinaire à raconter je
n'ai pas non plus vécu de drame en tout
cas suffisamment dramatique à mes yeux
qui pourrait potentiellement justifier
ou encore expliquer
mon déclic
ma révélation et mon attachement à la
vie
et pourtant j'aimerais vous inviter dans
mon univers partager avec vous ma
perception des choses
et avec un peu de générosité un bout de
mon parcours personnel
de mon cheminement personnel
parce que je suis persuadée et j'espoir
que chacun d'entre nous a un moment
prennent conscience qu'il détient la
réponse à la question qu'est-ce que la
vie
mon attachement pour la vie et ma
curiosité
remonte de manière consciente tout au
moins un dessin animé toute petite je
regardais il était une fois la vie un
dessin animé ludique enchanté et très
scientifique qui explique ce que la vie
biologique
bien sûr au cours de mon développement
et de mon évolution d'autres programmes
de vulgarisation
on nourrit cette curiosité
et au final tous
ont influencé de manière directe ou
indirecte mes choix et mes orientations
d'études alors j'ai fait un bac SVT
sciences de la vie et de la terre j'ai
fait aussi médecine
biologique sciences du vivant
développement cellulaire et reproduction
humaine embryologie physiologie cellules
souches à chaque fois l'objectif était
très simple aller plus loin le
rapprocher de l'origine de la vie
et d'une simple curiosité c'est
carrément devenu presque obsession car
il me fallait absolument comprendre
d'où tout partait
alors oui j'ai fini par trouver une
réponse très scientifique et aujourd'hui
je suis assez fière de dire que je suis
de bonne notions sur l'odyssée de la vie
sur les mécanismes de transmission du
bagage génétique ou encore comment
fonctionne les êtres vivants
je souris expliquer comment tout se
construit avec l'uni objectif de
préserver
la survie des espèces qu'elle soit
animal ou végétale d'ailleurs
je pourrais aussi expliquer comment
respirer qui nous semble simples si à
qui est en réalité ainsi que hyper
complexe de réactions chimiques
ou encore expliquer comment la
perception d'une goutte de pluie
active et stimule des qui me récepteurs
qui vont engendrer une cascade
d'hormones dans notre cerveau
je serai aussi expliqué
comment notre cœur
intelligemment arrive à se synchroniser
aux vibrations des champs des oiseaux
juste pour nous apaiser
vous voyez c'est extraordinaire
et pourtant
je pense que d'ailleurs ma passion pour
les cellules vient de tout cela
je trouve vraiment extraordinaire
qu'une si petite unité de vie puisse
faire d'aussi grands exploits
visualisons ensemble d'une cellule on en
obtient 2 puis 4 puis 8 pour passer
ensuite à un amas cellulaire ensuite à
des tissus à des organes à des systèmes
jusqu'à obtenir un être complet
complètement fonctionnel en capacité
d'interagir respirer sentir toucher
vibrer mais aussi d'agir finalement
et malgré tout ce que j'avais compris
c'est que cette cellule justement s'y
inspirante représentait un monde elle
seule elle était une organisation
secrète pragmatique et intelligente sa
mission transmettre la vie tout
simplement
pour même préserver préserver cette vie
elle était aussi en capacité de
programmer sa propre mort
la mort fait donc partie de la vie
et au final
malgré tout ce savoir
toutes ces informations rationnelles il
manquait quand même quelque chose
quelque chose de plus vivant
de la vraie vie en fait
à ma grande surprise j'ai eu d'autres
réponses
ce fut au moment j'ai moi-même donné la
vie à deux reprises
c'était différent parce que
j'expérimentais réellement et surtout de
manière consciente cette vie sa
complexité sa puissance et aussi sa
fragilité
j'ai aussi ressenti une connexion avec
d'autres vies antérieures celle de mes
ancêtres
celle que j'ai réussi à identifier la
plus ancienne c'est celle d'Anne Leia
matricule 24/18 esclave né au Gosier
et à sa vie ce sont additionnés celle
d'Adel sin de Constance
de Rennes
de Michel Danic
toutes ces femmes qui m'ont donné la vie
toutes ces femmes qui continuent à vivre
en moi
et à ces moments présents justement mais
je transmettais moi aussi la vie
je transmettais toutes ces vies
ce fut comme une renaissance je
comprenais enfin qui j'étais ce que
j'étais
paradoxalement j'avais aussi compris que
tout ce que j'avais cherché pendant tout
ce temps avait toujours été là
en moi
parce que pour tout vous dire je suis
cette vie
j'ai compris aussi
que cette vie en fait au final elle
jaillit en chacun de nous en chacun des
éléments vivants
de ce monde
c'était plus difficile pour moi au final
c'était de me rendre compte que j'avais
un mois tout ce potentiel et que je ne
l'avais jamais exploité
au final comme Karl
Gustave jungk un médecin suisse le dit
ce qui n'apprenne rien de désagréable
dans leur vie force la conscience
cosmique à le reproduire autant de fois
que nécessaire pour qu'ils apprennent ce
cancer le drame car ce que tu nies te
soumet et ce que tu acceptes te
transforme
la clé de la vie elle serait là alors
enfin l'accepter pour la transformer
pour l'incarner et arrêter de la subir
ce que j'ai compris également
c'est qu'au final
cette vie justement
elle était puissante et vulnérable
elle est éternelle car elle se transmet
mais en réalité ne tient qu'à un fil
elle est également universelle mais en
fait propre à chacun
et surtout le plus important c'est qu'en
réalité elle est ce que chacun décide
qu'elle est
aujourd'hui je vous invite à prendre
conscience de cela
je vous invite aussi à vous rendre
compte à quel point ce que nous avons de
plus cher en nous
et aussi celle que nous ce que nous
méprisons peut-être le plus
je pense également qu'au final
nous devons finalement accepter et
prendre confiance
nous devons aussi prendre le risque de
vivre pleinement cette vie
car pour tout vous dire
nous n'avons qu'une vie
nous avons toutes les vies en nous
alors que faisons-nous
quand faites-vous
dans mon expérience la plante a été une
source d'inspiration
en l'observant à chaque fois que j'ai
rencontré une problématique avec mes
filles
c'est bien elle qui m'a apporté des
éléments de réponse
elle assume indiquer comment agir ou
alors comment elle-même pouvait agir en
ma faveur
elle a soigné mon aîné de son problème
d'eczéma
et elle a nourri ma cadette de santé
alors pour moi l'évidence c'était
simplement de reconnaître sa vie juste
parce que en tant qu'être vivant elle
avait été aussi légitime que moi et que
nous étions interconnectés
alors j'ai développé une application qui
permettait de
diffuser ce pouvoir des plantes ou
encore j'ai créé une gamme d'aliments
vivants pour nourrir enfin nos enfants
avec justement toute cette vie ces
aliments ces antioxydants ces vitamines
merci la plante
merci de m'avoir reconnecté à la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]